hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and in this video i will be
discussing the tragic life
of sasha blaus someone who started out
as just a comic relief character
but quickly turned into a fan favorite
not to mention a genuinely well-written
and well-developed character
and so much more than just a potato meme
sasha underwent some truly incredible
character development
as i will argue in this video and she
left a powerful
and lasting impact on the people closest
to her in fact it was precisely this
legacy that sasha left behind
that finally led to some real character
progression
for attack on titan's most hated
character
so now it's time to dedicate our hearts
and talk about the life
of our precious potato girl sasha
if you enjoyed the attack on titan
videos right here on the channel and you
want us to keep it coming please
leave a like and a comment it only takes
a moment but it helps a lot
and if you're new to animal pro or maybe
you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications heads up this video
will contain spoilers
for the attack on titan manga sasha's
death has already been revealed in the
anime but i will be drawing on some
material that hasn't been covered in the
anime as of the making of this video so
please proceed with caution
you have been warned sasha was of course
a pivotal member of the survey corps who
died in action during the attack on
liberia
the mission to attack liberio itself was
a massive strategic success
as the survey corps members managed to
decimate the marlin forces
capture the warhammer titan and take out
many leaders of the marlene military
all in one fell swoop but tragically
sasha was shot and killed by gabby brown
just as the survey corps members were
preparing to leave lebario
on board an airship gabby and falco
managed to sneak aboard the airship
and gabby shot sasha before both her and
falco were subdued
by the survey corps in the aftermath of
sasha's death
both falco and gabby were captured and
taken to parodies
as prisoners my earliest memories of
sasha are of a funny and carefree girl
who absolutely
loves food so much so that she is
willing to risk
severe punishment for just a single
delicious potato
sasha was always a special and extremely
memorable character in attack on titan
precisely because she provides comic
relief in an
otherwise extremely bleak and cruel
world
in fact according to the attack on titan
character encyclopedia the creator of
attack on titan hajime isayama
apparently named sasha after the
comedian sasha baron cohen
you know that borat guy so isayama
always intended for sasha to be a comic
relief character
at least at first but as the story
progressed
sasha's character became much more than
just a meme
she became more complex more interesting
and much more developed isayama
initially wanted to kill
sasha off way back in volume 9 of the
story but his
editor convinced him to change his mind
by that point
sasha had become a fan favorite and it
was clear that her character had
amazing potential in terms of her
backstory
sasha grew up in a small village inside
wal rose that was overwhelmed by
newcomers
after the fall of wal-maria because the
villagers relied on hunting to survive
their way of life was quickly turned
upside down as the supply of wildlife
could not support
both the native villagers and the
refugees from wall maria
sasha was initially extremely upset by
this and she did not want to change her
traditional way of life for the sake of
accommodating the newcomers
in fact sasha got into an argument with
her father
after her father decided that helping
people was more important than
preserving their way of life
sasha's father concluded that the
villagers should switch focus from
hunting to farming
because farming was a more efficient way
to feed more people
sasha was so upset by her father's
decision that she decided to leave the
village
and join the military once she does join
the military
sasha becomes a member of the 104th
training corps
sasha quickly became infamous for her
appetite
and her obsession with food even in the
most inappropriate situations
she becomes known as potato girl after
she gets caught
stealing a potato when her instructor
keith shadis
publicly questions her about the potato
she tries to bribe him by giving him
half of the potato and then the piece
that she actually offers him
is way less than half sasha's behavior
during this
otherwise incredibly tense situation is
absolutely hilarious and even keith
who at this point is doing his best to
look like a strict and stern instructor
is completely flabbergasted by sasha's
behavior
as are all of the other recruits they
just have no idea how to
even react i actually just rewatched
this scene
in preparation for this video and it is
just as funny as i remember it
despite knowing exactly what was going
to happen when i rewatched it i
genuinely laughed out loud
it was that funny so yes initially sasha
was a comic relief character who offered
some much needed humor in an otherwise
extremely dark story
sasha was likable right away but her
character
wasn't very complex at the beginning of
the story however as the story goes on
sasha continues to evolve and she
eventually becomes
an amazing character despite her
goofiness and obsession with food sasha
eventually becomes
a top class sharpshooter and she ends up
finishing
9th in her graduating class which
is actually extremely impressive when
you consider who the other members of
the 104th
training corps were including emir there
are five titan shifters
and one ackerman in that class and yet
sasha was still in the top ten but
sasha's character development really
takes off when she risks her life to
save a little girl named kaya
from a titan in chapter 36 of the manga
and
episode 27 of the anime sasha stumbles
upon
a gruesome scene in a mostly abandoned
village
she finds a small titan who is in the
process of
eating a woman the woman's young
daughter is there as well
but she is completely paralyzed from the
shock even though sasha doesn't have her
vertical maneuvering gear
she still decides to take on the titan
first she attacks him with an axe and
then later with a bow and arrow
sasha ultimately manages to blind the
titan and save the little girl's life
the courage and determination that sasha
shows here just to save a complete
stranger
tells us everything we need to know
about her character the village that the
little girl lived in was actually a new
one
and it was located near sasha's own
village
this means that the people who live in
this village are newcomers
the same people that sasha was annoyed
by earlier on in her life
because they had interfered with her
traditional way of life
and yet by this point in the story sasha
had already matured so much that she
willingly risks her life and fights a
titan without the proper gear
in order to save the life of one of
these newcomers
that is how much sasha had evolved as a
person in such a short period of time
so it's no wonder that she quickly
became a fan favorite character
during the attack on the barrio sasha
again demonstrates her incredible skill
as a sharpshooter her skills were
instrumental in taking down
peak's cart titan and she also played a
key role in pacifying the other marlene
forces in the area
at one point during the attack sasha
actually had gabby
in her line of sight but because gabby
was just a child
sasha made the conscious decision not to
shoot her
even though she was a soldier in enemy
territory sasha was not willing to kill
a child
and that split second decision ended up
costing her her life
as we know at the very end of the attack
on the barrio just as it looked like the
survey corps members were about to
successfully escape
aboard the airship gabby manages to
climb up onto the airship and she
shoots sasha with a rifle sasha
eventually succumbs to her wounds
and gabby and falco are apprehended and
taken to parody's island
sasha's death was truly tragic
especially since it happened just as it
looked like the mission was over
and all of our favorite characters had
made it out in one piece
but as tragic as sasha's death was
this was not the end of sasha's story
the lasting legacy that she leaves
behind and her impact on the lives of
two people in particular
continues to speak to the beauty of her
character
the two people that i'm referring to are
kaya and
niccolo i already mentioned kaya the
girl whose life sasha had saved
and as it turns out kaia returns to the
story
after gabby and falco are taken to
parodies
during their stay on parodies gabby and
falco manage to escape their captivity
and while on the run they eventually
meet kaia
kaiya doesn't know who the two of them
are but she overhears them talking about
being from marley
now even though they are technically the
citizens of an
enemy nation kaia decides to help gabby
and falco and she actually helps to hide
their identities so that they wouldn't
be apprehended by the authorities on
parodies
even though this is extremely risky for
kaya
she believes that helping gabby and
falco is the right
thing to do and so she is willing to put
her own
safety and maybe even her own life on
the line
in order to help two strangers from an
enemy nation
one of the main reasons why kaia is so
willing to help others
including complete strangers is her love
for
sasha after kaya was rescued by sasha
she was raised by sasha's family as one
of her own and she came to see sasha
as an older sister she also began
looking up to sasha and she wanted to
become
just like her since sasha was willing to
risk her own life to save kaya
back when kaia was a complete stranger
to her kaya believed that she also had a
duty to help
others no matter who they are and this
includes gabby and falco
now kaya obviously did not know that
gabby was the one who killed sasha when
she decided to help her and falco
and when she does find out that this is
the case kaya is furious at gabby which
is perfectly understandable
however kaia's kind treatment of gabby
and falco before she knew what gabi had
done
is what finally begins to open gabby's
eyes
slowly but surely gabby finally comes to
understand that the people on paradise
are not all bad and as it turns out
she had been lied to her whole life
about these so-called
island devils thanks to kaia and the
rest of sasha's family
gabby finally undergoes the character
development that she had desperately
been lacking
and ironically it is all thanks to sasha
the person that gabby had killed the
other person that i want to talk about
here
is niccolo nicolo is an ethnic marlian
who was captured by the forces on
parodies
after a marlene survey ship was seized
by aaron during the time skip
even though he was an enemy captive on
the island nicolo was treated with
kindness by sasha
and she absolutely loved his cooking as
a matter of fact
nicolo seems to have developed a close
relationship with sasha
and his interactions with her completely
changed his mind about the so-called
island devils
nicolo also became close with sasha's
family
and kaya believed that nikola and sasha
were in love
when she finds out about this gabby is
shocked at the very
thought that a marleian and an aldian
could be in love
but it's true even though she was
technically an enemy soldier going off
to attack his own homeland
nikola was absolutely devastated when he
learned that sasha had died
during the attack on lebario and when
nikola finds out that gabby was the one
who killed sasha
nikola attacks her and he hands sasha's
father a knife
offering him the chance to kill his
daughter's assassin
he also says to sasha's father that if
he won't kill gabby
then niccolo himself will do it that's
right an ethnic marlayan and a member of
the marland military
cared so much about sasha this so-called
island
devil that he was willing to kill gabby
on honorary marlene and warrior cadet in
the marlan military just to avenge
sasha luckily for gabby sasha's parents
are extremely good
and kind people and they ultimately
refused to kill gabi
even if she was the one who killed their
daughter
but the words that nicolo says to gabby
during this confrontation have really
stuck with me
when he realizes that falco is clearly
important to gabby
nicolo says the following i had someone
important to me once
too that's right an eldian a descendant
of
devils but she enjoyed my food more than
anyone i'd met before
she saved me from this stupid worthless
war
she showed me who i was meant to be
someone who brings people happiness
through his food that was sasha blouse
the woman whose life you took
wow that is what i meant when i said
earlier on in this video that sasha's
story did not end
with her death her legacy lived on
and it continues to shape the story
after
sasha's passing after this intense
standoff with nicolo and sasha's family
gabby finally changes her way of
thinking
she finally develops as a character and
she realizes that the islanders
are not evil devils they are regular
people just like everyone else
and some of them are kinder and more
compassionate than gabby herself was
ever willing to be but none of that
development could have been possible
without sasha i know that a lot of
people wanted gabby to pay for what she
had done to sasha
right away they wanted her to be
punished to be killed
right there on the airship as soon as
sasha died
but if that had happened if gabi had
died before meeting sasha's family and
nicolo
she would have died believing that what
she did was the right
thing she would have died believing that
sasha was some evil island devil who
deserved
to die but because gabby lived
she lived long enough to regret what she
had done
she lived long enough to understand who
sasha really was and how
wrong gabby had been about the aldeans
on paradise
island as tragic and heartbreaking as
sasha's death was
her life was actually amazing and
beautiful
and while she was here she was a breath
of fresh air
in a dark and cruel world she left a
lasting impact that will continue to
shape the lives and decisions of the
people who were close to her
people like kaya and niccolo and in fact
sasha's powerful legacy ultimately
destroyed the bigotry and prejudice
of her own assassin how absolutely
poetic
is that sasha's legacy transformed gabby
her
own assassin as a person and i am sure
that this
is exactly what sasha would have wanted
she wouldn't have wanted some sort of
violent revenge
she would have wanted gabby to
understand the truth she would have
wanted gabby to free herself
from the lies and propaganda that had
poisoned her for her entire life
and precisely because sasha left such a
lasting
impact on kaya and niccolo and on
everyone else around her
in the end that is exactly what happened
sasha may have started out as a meme
character
but eventually our potato girl became
so much more and her legacy will never
die thank you guys so much for watching
this video and if you did enjoy it
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help
also if you're new to the channel or
maybe you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all i know it's annoying it's an extra
step but if you don't do that you're
still gonna miss a ton of our videos
even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple of lord twego himself and i
can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above
all other clans including ingrata
the world acquired respect pate heffa
liam thompson algital
dr cortman johnny boy draws emperor
otaku
spidey life canal big buddhist and
tungsten tarkis
finally thank you to all of our pro-hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers
angel cruz anatoly kazatsky joe stanton
very gucci jessica calefon rathune
deyora alicia octa bonnie parks hinokami
and water the red-haired raven joanne
garcia jack watches anime fat boy games
deadly saint
matthew cruz and anthony schreiber if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you